how did the rich get richer because  fundamentally rich people like pay less  for [ __ ] their business in and of itself  is more valuable than what they're  buying right now every gym in Vegas  except for one I have a free membership  at because if I do one story or people  just know that I'm going there they're  gonna get more than one member for me so  it makes sense but I think that that  happens all over the place at the end of  the day it's like you always just have  to become more valuable to make more  money so we're gonna save more money is  it fair yes that's why people do it  because it's a fair trade people don't  do things that are not in their  self-interest the problem is that the  people who are so self-interested never  benefit anyone else and then wonder why  everyone makes them pay for [ __ ] because  they benefit the other person zero  percent